can I start with an update on the Prime
Minister he's still in intensive care
but he continues to make positive step
forwards and he's in good spirits and I
can also report from the government
ongoing monitoring and testing program
that as of today two hundred and forty
three thousand four hundred and
twenty-one people have been tested for
the virus sixty five thousand and
seventy seven have tested positive and
the number of people admitted to
hospital with coronavirus symptoms now
stands at sixteen thousand seven hundred
and eighty four and of those who have
contracted the virus seven thousand nine
hundred and seventy eight have sadly
died and our thoughts and our prayers
are with their families and their
friends the whole country has been
practicing a stringent form of social
distancing for three weeks now precisely
because we're doing everything we can to
minimize the bleak numbers that I just
read out and for that I want to say a
massive thank you to everyone who's gone
the extra mile during this very
challenging period thank you to all of
those who are looking after us in our
time of need the NHS workers on the
front line who have treated the sick
saved lives and tended for those who
sadly could not be saved for the doctors
and nurses who have died of coronavirus
whilst caring for others we will never
forget their sacrifice we will never
forget their devotion to helping others
I also want to say big thank you to the
carers the charity workers all those
looking after or even just keeping an
eye on those in their local
neighbourhood you are the lifeline to so
many people in our communities thank you
to the workers who keep the country
running the supermarket work is the
delivery drivers the technicians the
cleaners the public servants who just
kept going determined to keep providing
the daily services that we all rely on
I think you've certainly made us all
think long and hard about who the key
workers are in our lives thank you to
the volunteers who have stepped up
across the country
whose big-hearted sense of
responsibility defines British community
spirit at its very best and a massive
thank you to every single person who
stayed home to stop this terrible virus
from spreading
you've helped protect the NHS and you've
helped to save lives now as we look onto
the look forward to the long bank
holiday Easter weekend I know some
people are going to start wondering is
it time to ease up on the rules so I
have to say thank you for your sacrifice
but also we're not done yet
we must keep going let me just explain a
little bit about why that's so important
today I chaired a Cobra meeting with
senior ministers officials and
represented representatives from
Scotland Wales Northern Ireland as well
as the Mayor of London so that we could
take stock and assess where we are right
across the United Kingdom and at this
stage the government is continuing to
gather all of the relevant data to
obtain the fullest picture possible of
the effects of the social distancing
measures that we've put in place now
while the early signs suggest that they
are having the impact that we need to
see it's too early to say that
conclusively
saij will meet next week to discuss the
latest evidence and we'll keep the
measures we've put in place under review
as we've said on many occasions now
we'll be guided by the science at all
times so we don't expect to be able to
say more on this until the end of next
week
and let me just be again very clear
about this the measures will have to
stay in place until we've got the
evidence that clearly shows we've moved
beyond the peak now I know these
restrictions take their doll take their
toll day-in day-out on people's
livelihoods on people's quality of life
on people's mental health and I
appreciate that it's often the little
things that hurt the most with the
Easter Bank holiday coming up I'd
normally spend it with my two boys seven
and five years old with their
grandparents doing an Easter egg hunt
and I know there's going to be lots of
people who would normally be planning a
family
together or just getting out in the
sunshine with friends and loved ones
unfortunately right now we just can't do
those sorts of things and I'm really
sorry about that but just take a moment
to think of the progress that we've
already made following the guidance
staying at home denying the virus or it
needs to spread more easily and to kill
more people it's been almost three weeks
and we're starting to see the impact of
the sacrifices we've all made but the
deaths are still rising and we haven't
yet reached the peak of the virus so
it's still too early to lift the
measures that we've put in place we must
stick to the plan and we must continue
to be guided by the science our top
priority our immediate priority remains
to slow the spread of the virus and to
save as many lives as possible and
that's why we have to continue to ask
you to keep complying with the guidance
and as we've said consistently from the
outset it's vital we take the right
decisions at the right time and the
might and the most important thing right
now is that people continue to follow
the government's guidance until we've
got the evidence
that the virus is firmly under control
so that means please do stay at home to
protect our NHS and to save lives after
all the efforts that everyone's made
after all the sacrifices so many people
have made let's not ruin it now let's
not undo the gains we've made let's not
waste the sacrifices so many people have
made we mustn't give the coronavirus a
second chance to kill more people and to
hurt our country I know it's tough going
but this is a team effort and we'll only
defeat this virus for good if we all
stay the course so please stay home this
bank holiday weekend for everyone's sake